we're gonna work on the middle game
today and I prepared to show you one of
my games you haven't seen before it's
from 2014 chess olympiad where I played
for the US team in Norway and in this
game we were facing a very strong team
from Germany and you know one of the
crucial matches towards the end of the
Olympiad so I'm playing with white
pieces my opponent is a strong 26:40
Grandmaster Daniel Friedman from Germany
and I played d4 he played Knight f6 c4
e6 you will see we're going to focus on
middle game today middle game an endgame
combined because you will see how I
played in a middle game you'll be in
charge of finding the most and known as
well in endgame Knight f3 d5 Bishop e7
so here we have which opening we have
after Bishop e7 he is an Enzo Indian
player so that's why I start with Knight
f3 here if I played nice e3 he will play
Bishop before so 9 f 3 D 5 and now 93
Bishop e7 what is the name of this
opening
any ideas what opening block is playing
you should notice Queens gambit the
client that's the correct answer
qgd remember that now White has a couple
of options here can play Bishop f5 or
can play Bishop g5 so two options here
possible so I opted to play Bishop to g5
okay now it plays h6 questioning my
bishop
I have Bishop f4 I've played before as
well so I play both moves here equal the
bishop h4 or Bishop four so here he
played h6 questioning me now what is the
main move here correct now he cancelled
yes absolutely correct
III just trying to get my development re
ghost Knight e4 he's activating his
Knight this is a very fashionable line
it's called a scale variation and the
block is trying to exchange couple of
pieces and just equalize so Knight e4
now what are you going to do here yes
no no Bishop is hanging on h4
so remember he wants to take on h4 so
you have to do something to prevent that
what do you have to play here he wants
to take your Bishop we have couple of
options here what are you supposed to do
correct very good Bishop takes c7 Queen
takes is 7 Queen c2 is one of the
options what else what else we can try
to do here you can play Queen c2 here or
you can play the following move you
could but then he takes on c3 and
there's some weaknesses better something
better you can do here you want to bring
which piece into the game here
he already mentioned the bishop there is
another piece you want to bring it to
the game in the back which piece is not
developed for you
of course look see one of course rook c1
you want to bring the rook into the game
because you want to open up that C file
okay so you open it up okay
c6 now what to do after c6 yes Bishop d3
is a possibility what else do you see
here what about this move
have you seen this idea before this is a
very interesting fashionable move first
time played in the game Aronian versus
Hari Krishna in 2011 World Team
Championship Aronian actually started
with the move h4 but that allows some
other possibilities so but dear I wanted
to start with the G Force
now he goes Knight to d7 developing the
night now what you're going to do here
is h4 when you pull g4 you're going to
push h4 you're trying to gain space
playing very aggressive style Queen's
Gambit the client is a very solid
opening so you want to play aggressively
if you want to get advantage against it
now he chose to take on c3 how are we
going to capture here more hands should
be raised at the moment because you know
the move what's the logical way to do it
of course with the rook that's why you
brought the rook in right if you weren't
going to take back with the rook then
you were not going to play the move rook
c1 so remember logical play and hear my
opponent played c5 trying to break the
center very interesting decision other
moves are playable as well to take on c4
and maybe play e5 immediately
there's also consideration what he took
he played c5 he is immediately trying to
break the center now if everything comes
off exchange you place b6 B should be
seven I will be left with just
weaknesses so I have to play very
precisely here if I want to have any
kind of advantage here will be three as
possible what else
Queen b3 you can take so what else can
you do don't rush you don't want this
diagonal to be open okay because if
that's diagonal it's open then you can
have some problems because you have a
lot of weaknesses that's when my goal
was to try to make sure this diagonal
remains closed what are you going to do
to keep this long diagonal closed in a
sense so this Bishop doesn't come - in
the back take where C takes d5 you were
referring to
correct he takes back now now what's the
logical move here you always have to
make logical moves yes not yet
g5 first because I want to open up the
position here I want to take and expose
this King if he takes I want to take
with the H pawn and then I have the H
file so I kind of knew he is going to
play the move H five years I knew he was
going to do that because anything else
his position is going to be very exposed
and now who's more visit Bishop g2
perfect now he played the move b6 my
question to you is if he plays c4 what
are you going to do because this looks
like a very logical move then you play
b5 what is the move here do you see that
subtle move here that is going to allow
you to win upon two hands that's good
more hand should be though who sees that
subtle move here that I had in mind now
four hands good know you want to win
upon win upon thing that that those are
moves doesn't know but it's a subtle
move you do something and then suddenly
to
phones are hanging here yes he's got it
he's got it
attack attack that's what you're
referring to right see that no b5 Bishop
d5 he's not going to give it up on so he
has to play Knight b6 and then you take
he goes Bishop f5 and now you have a
good move what is the good move here
it's actually very important you find
the following move it's very very
important that you do that because he
has threats he wants to pay clean before
create problems
yes
a tree but also he wants to play night a
for to attack a3s night a for us well
here's to turrets now Queen before and
night a for and you have to do something
to defend against those threats
what is the move fish very difficult
move to find because we don't think that
we should play moves like that you know
but sometimes that's the best way to do
it to defend the threats you want to
pause at the moment to defend against
the threats so let's see yes
no night xt5 losing the piece you know
you cannot afford to lose your bishop
there your bishop is playing a very
important rules anybody else was to try
Queen d1 he's got it there
excellent move Queen d1 now you're
stopping Knight a for now he goes Queen
two before attacking you now what is the
move that you have in mind that subtle
move here very strong yes now he plays
94 attacking you what are you going to
do huh you not afraid here you're not
afraid to lose your rook thank you take
the central pawn don't be afraid okay he
takes you take now he goes back you also
have this you can even take this one if
you want to or you have a very good
position here because you have a lot of
central pawns okay this is good too
well it's very concrete so this is very
concrete position in general you don't
want to do that but you know in chess we
have exceptions so this is an exception
here so we not wait too much about that
so so this is what he saw I know that he
was worried and this is again a very
experienced Grandmaster Rampling I'm not
just playing some new young GM this is a
very experienced and masters who has
played a lot of strong players before so
he played the move be six now what to do
now he wants to play Bishop d7 and he
actually wants to play Bishop ace six
years and that would be kind of annoying
because it would prevent me from
castling so what's the idea here
because if it puts the bishop on b7 put
the pawn on g6 it's very comfortable so
this is the moment where I have to try
to play it correctly
let's see yes correct decision correct
decision because now defy phone is
hanging so if it takes back with a pawn
we take only fat but of course he's
going to take that with a knight and a
question is are you ready to take that
pawn look super dangerous I would say
because if you take that pawn it's super
dangerous he's going to go Bishop b7 now
what are you going to do you're in
trouble he's going to put the rookie you
are in big big trouble here okay so
that's why you don't want to do that now
what can you do here dink-dink logical
here it's not about castling here it's
about putting the piece in the middle of
the board centralizing it remember
centralizing and blocking that isolated
pawn that millpond in the middle is the
iso Lonnie okay so what is the correct
move here what is the correct move here
yes correct decision yes blockading it
and attacking the pawn on h5 as well
okay blockading the past in attacking
now I'm also attacking this pawn at the
same time see when opponent has isolated
pawn you need to remember to block it
that's a rule number one everybody make
a note make a note so you remember if
opponent has a weak isolated pawn first
thing to do is to block it to make sure
he cannot push it now it was 94
attacking my rook again it's a sharp
position it's not so clear if I have
anything here so now yes what's the
decision needs to be made here
absolutely correct Bishop takes the
knight is too strong in the middle of
the board we just take with the bishop
we simply eliminated now if he takes
back with the pawn he is losing the pawn
on h5 he is in trouble
so he has to take back with the Queen
and now he's attacking a rook
your rook is under attack now now you
need to make a good positional move to
control some with a lot slight squares
because he is controlling that so what's
that good positional move I'm referring
to here more hands we have two very
active participants more hands though
and this is a very typical move for this
kind of positions when you have a
control of the dark squares you also
want to obtain the control of the light
squares okay so what do you think here
what do you think yes go ahead
f3 another correct decision another very
strong positional decision here and
attacking the Queen the queen is
centralized by playing f3 gyro removing
the piece from that centralized position
this should be a very natural move for
you some of you didn't raise your hand
wasn't this just an obvious move here to
play but the Queen look at the Queen
it's in my position is attacking my rook
is attacking the h1 do you want that
piece there or you want to push that
piece away both Bishop g4 you get really
badly pin there Knight remember when you
have a black head like this you never
want to move it you never want to move
the black head piece like this remember
in any circumstances you don't want to
move that piece f3 is natural move you
should remember this move and play it
always in a similar positions 25 now he
wants to go clean g3 check what you're
going to do are you going to allow him
to do that
now this is a very important moment here
because I have some ideas to hear what
can I do here he wants to go : g3 check
obviously you cannot allow that to
happen
let's see if you can play this correct
move here yes
hag king f2 is a playable move yeah it's
a playable move simply controlling the
g3 Square and getting ready to play
getting ready to play which move now
because you want to exchange the Queens
after board here if you exchange the
quiz after board somehow you will have a
superior endgame so how are you going to
achieve that superior endgame here yes
excellent move yes attacking the Queen
how did you find that move very strong
very strong thinking yes now you're
attacking the Queen he has to go here
and I pick with a bat this move
unfortunately turn out to be an
inaccuracy it's a very natural mobile
turn out to be in accuracy here actually
I had to play a different move had to
enter into his position first and then
play Queen f3 that will make a big
difference of course when you analyze
afterwards with a computer it simply
shows you the best move but during the
game I didn't know it what should I have
done first here absolutely rook belongs
where we know that rooks belong where
everybody on a seventh rank but during
the game it was difficult to understand
this subtlety that I need to activate my
book first attacking the bishop and if
it goes Bishop g4 what do we have here
in mind you have to play this move
because otherwise this whole concept is
not going to work my rook is under
attack that's why I didn't play this
move I was worried about this but I have
a very strong move here to neutralize
his position you want to exchange the
Queens remember but row your rook is
under attack as well your rook is under
attack as well and that makes it a
difficult
yes and he's got it this is what I
missed I missed the smooth had I not
missed this I would have won this game
much easier because now it's complete
domination Queens will have to come off
the board my knight is there my rookies
on a seventh rank big trouble I mean
imagine if he doesn't want to trade
question so make a move like this and
after this I control the C file as well
I missed that subtlety so I played this
right away still securing an advantage
but it was not easy to win against this
experience grandmasters so he took I
took Brooke fc8 he's the exchanging pair
of the book so my next one was pretty
clear
Oh gate c1 takes takes and if he
exchanges the if he exchanges the rooks
it's going to be a problem for him
because my king is too active but he's
not doing that he is playing here now I
want you to pause here for a moment and
evaluate this position now I want you to
pause for two minutes and evaluate this
position and I would like each of you to
say something about this position the
pure prospective it's clear that white
is better I think but why and how much
that's what we want to find out the
problem is for me that I can get in but
then he just simply comes here and gets
my look out of the way that's the
problem what do you think this position
how much of course if I'm my roopa zone
I played Roxy seven early there will be
much better advantage but now okay raise
your hand if you're ready to to say how
much advantage here yes
okay but you think how big is our
advantage here 96 is it's an interesting
move but now it's white to move here
rook rook c7 kingi 8 so let's see what
can you say more about this position
first of all let's figure out how big is
this advantage how big is this advantage
so the question is is the big advantage
or a slight advantage sheesh yeah I
think it's more like a slight advantage
definitely very pleasant and nice
position but it's slight okay because I
don't have a clear way of breaking
through here so here I started with b3
move just to control some more squares
and here I want to expand on a queen set
to potentially create some weaknesses
when I was King D 6 now he's ready to
play you know like maybe even prepared
slowly Drock c8 you know a six rook c8
so I figure I have to play this I give
him a check if he goes back I can get in
with my rock so he took it I took it
even though it looks like I shouldn't
exchange but here my knight is not so
much better than his bishop it looks
better by optically not optically it
looks better but in fact it's not so
much better okay so you need to
understand that so now that's why when
check and now we have a control of the C
file and there is a weak pawn here as
well and by the way at this moment
Team USA was losing by one so it was
important to score a victory to at least
tie up the match
unfortunately gata Kamsky lost with
black again toward Mya
so we were down by one here and there
was a draw on a fourth port and likely a
drawn a first board so if I had not won
this
again we would lose the match to Germany
so I had to push until the very end eh
to try to secure at least tie this match
up
now he goes King be seven just
retreating with the king now now what
are we going to do here yes before I
went Brooke c1 because I wanted to have
the option to go to k1 as well so that's
why to tie him up completely
so he goes e6 he didn't want to be tied
up
so if they'd a six and now what is the
correct move yes pin it to win it then
again we see this idea pin it to win it
now he goes here and now
now we stretch the position now and
there is a big weakness on b6 now what
are we going to do here before he will
play a four he will pushed it now they
will be six pawn is the weakness now you
want to do what put pressure on it
noe for you don't want to play d5 is his
witness you want to go back rook d1 look
at the technique here attack he goes
here back it's actually not so good
because he goes here
and now lose this guy could be trouble
big trouble for us and then he will have
two pounds on one create the outside
passed pawn he might push for a victory
here
he might push for the victory I'm not
sure if you succeeded but he might even
try to push it okay so that's why we
don't want to allow this first we have
to improve our roof right now so that's
what I'm doing I'm attacking him
stretching him because if he goes here I
have a for winning a pot so he has to go
here and I go back now I wanna go to c6
now he goes here now look at this idea I
want to bring the King to d4 now okay he
goes back Luke c6 now I attacked the
pawn now he realized the problem if he
defends passively he's just going to
slowly lose my king is coming so he
bails out I kick he attacks my pawn I go
behind it takes I take I still have to
convert this position it looks very
promising but still it's a rock endgame
and we know this is a very could be very
draw still you have to show a good
technique to win this position he goes
King g6 if you go here I will give you a
check and I pick up your F 7 g7 you lose
immediately so that's why you don't want
to do that now what is the plan here now
which piece needs to be improved is rook
my rook 105 is it the best squad for my
rook it should be where it ideally
should be behind the past pawn but we
cannot do that because his rook is - so
we want to improve it and put it where
absolutely rook a6 check here he goes
King f5
Luque seven attacking it and now if he
goes back I will just go King B seven
and here he decided to throw the last
ditch she know this move to just create
a mess but luckily this was move for yet
so this was the last time control move
for him he just tossed it in hoping that
something will come out out of it but
now I had my time I had my thirty
minutes now to think and calculate and I
calculated all the way through until the
victory now let's see if you can do that
you have a victory here important
matchup here calculate it all the way
through come on so this is where things
get complicated you have to stay calm
and just continue calculating keep that
ability to calculate precisely you have
to have keep the keep it calm and
calculate so what is the correct move
here yes excellent decision check now he
has couple of options you can't even
hear well if he goes here I just take
another pile of g7 so it's losing if he
goes here I will insert one more check
and then I just take only four and g7
it's winning if he goes here now can you
find a winning move it's a very cool
move here you have to find very cool
move if you don't find this move I'm not
sure if you winning this game I'm not
sure if there's going to be a victory
yes and he's got it that's the correct
answer
Bravo Ruka faith yes now if he takes
check you go where and if he goes here
push check push check look at that
checkmate see how that works and if you
go now here what are you gonna do what
are you gonna do
correct now you want to push he's going
to go here what are you going to do
check big material advantage okay show
victory King is on a back rank and you
have two pawns as well all right so
that's why he didn't go here if he goes
back I already told you you just take
this one and I mean too many pawns here
okay big material advantage early king
of King d2 as well in the twist better
two pounds up so that's why he went here
now things are getting a little
complicated so what are we going to do
here to make sure they're not that
complicated
thank you so yes what's the move I just
took this spawn I didn't want him to
keep taking me so best way to avoid him
from taking you you take him by the way
I am three pounds up currently that's a
lot that's a lot you know so he takes
one down now
yes not bg6
yes I know it looks a little bit strange
but the point of this move is he can
only take this pawn which you didn't do
but if it takes this I take it then I
can go back to f7 and continue pushing
the Jeep on I didn't want to take on g7
because then he would have taken on f4
so this is a very important but now he
cuts me off he cuts me off now what are
you supposed to do d5
how about f5 with idea f6 I think you
would like to do that because then you
push it again so he was king f4 f6 he
takes it g7 look g3 how about that and
the question is if you can find a very
subtle move here to ensure the victory
who is going to find this move it's a
really nice move because your pawns a
little bit weak and if he comes and
takes your D pawn you're going to be in
trouble here which one kingi v kinky v
yes yeah well don't don't play that move
with you you might spoil the victory
here very nice move here who is going to
find this technical move here a couple
of hands you would like to smooth and
once you find it and you understand what
am I trying to do with this
it's not about defending here Ben he
cannot take the D pawn with the rook
it's more like trying to promote one of
the paths not defending because if you
play rook d7 he play a5 you play d5
he goes King if a little bit stuck there
it's about I cannot say that word
because then you'll find it yes Bravo
cut the King off do you see now what
happened now the king is cut off and now
you know much this one down it's slow
but it's effective and that's what
matters right effective because his rook
cannot move from there Chifa because
we're going to Quinn and his King cannot
even go to the g5 because we're going to
Quinn
see how affected that is and his F
pollens blocked that's a final neat
touch shortly seven right there I
actually saw this move earlier that's
why I went for this position because I
knew that this is going to be a sure
victory now he gave me a check King F 1
attacking the rook and he resigned here
because he cannot do anything to prevent
push push push and Queen and by the way
if he goes here now what would be a nice
finish here for white
rook III check deflecting the king he
takes it you take it and then you
promote upon into a queen okay very good
so after a clicking f1 he resigned
because King after he doesn't work and
if he stays on this what are we doing
how are we going to win this just push
the pawn he goes here no threats push
the pawn no threats again if it goes
here you can even Queen because if it
checks you you have this one so I mean
there are other things you can do you
can go King b1 and win but yes so and if
he sits we just push the pond okay very
good so that was the idea of this game
very important okay so yeah I was very
happy to win and yet it saved the match
this win so very interesting game but
you saw in the middle game especially
how tricky the position was how many
nuances there was in a middle game that
you had to master in order to get that's
why the middle game is very important
it's one of the toughest you know
moments worried in the game where it's
not so easy what you need to do but you
have to just spend your time and try to
find a good plan yeah that was more like
a opening idea g4 but after that it was
it was not my dear I which as I edges
display on my own so I just try to make
good moves
you know g5 Bishop g2 and make sure I
made the right decisions so it was very
kind of a risky opening for me but then
a very strong positional game where I
got a small advantage and then I
couldn't maybe get bigger advantage I
missed one move if you remember rook c7
then I got again a small advantage but
played a really good endgame until the
very end to convert it so there were a
lot of very interesting stages of sharp
opening then positional Milla game then
again small edge in endgame and just
kind of grind down the Luke endgame to
get the win any questions you have about
the
scam do you understand the ideas so if
somebody plays the Queens gambit decline
you can very well respond with this move